I'm Laura Ingram this is the Ingram
angle on a breaking news night tonight
America is seeing the ultimate an
election interference as four unelected
state judges all appointed by Democrat
Governors have ruled that Donald Trump
must be kept off next year's
presidential ballot the Colorado Supreme
Court in a 4-3 decision wrote that we
conclude that because president Trump is
disqualified from holding the office of
president under Section three of the
14th Amendment it would be a wrongful
act under the election code for the
secretary to list Trump as a candidate
on the presidential primary ballot
therefore the secretary may not list
president Trump's name on the 2024
presidential primary B nor may she count
any right in votes cast for him now the
suit focused on that section three of
the 14th Amendment that's aimed that was
aimed at barring Confederates from
federal office who engaged in
insurrectionist Behavior or Rebellion
now remember the case was spearheaded by
a left-wing group called citizens for
responsibility and ethics in Washington
that's great now the Trump legal team
will need to move fast and appeal this
to the Supreme Court of the United
States the decision of the Colorado
Supreme Court is stayed or delayed until
January 4th which is a key deadline in
uh being able to qualify for the ballot
here to react Jonathan
Fox News contributor and law professor
at GW University Jonathan to think that
for
unelected State Court judges could
conceivably end up determining the
presidential
election is something I think most
Americans are just shaking their head
tonight saying this can't be the United
States no it is a strikingly
anti-democratic uh holding in my view uh
the court literally faced a series of
interpretive barriers to get to where it
ended up it adopted the most sweeping
broadest possible interpretation to get
over every one of those hurdles so
throughout this opinion it had to adopt
uh
interpretations that could Encompass a
wide array of statements you know they
used what's called true threat precedent
to show that you can view the uh what
Trump said as encouraging an
Insurrection by looking at stuff that he
said at other times and that of course
allowed them to reach this conclusion in
my view the court is dead wrong this is
the first major win for these uh
Challengers they've gone to a number of
blue States this is one of the bluest
State Supreme Courts you can get to even
with that it's split um I think the
opinion uh is really chilling and I
think that the Supreme Court will make
fast work of this Theory I hope it does
but I think this court I think did great
damage to its own Integrity uh with this
opinion and there have been other
rulings in other state Supreme Courts
correct or federal courts that have um
come to the opposite conclusion here so
this is an outlier which again because
of what's at stake it's going to have to
be expedited to the court the Supreme
Court yeah when you read this opinion uh
the one thing that keeps on recurring in
in your mind is where's the limiting
principle here what would not satisfy
this test at each one of these barriers
the court could have adopted a fairly
moderate or more narrow approach but it
didn't and so on every one of these
issues uh it really took out all the
fail safes and went to the broadest
possible meaning well that means that
states could engage in a tit fortat type
of uh series of decisions you know you
could have red States uh blocking Biden
on some ballots and blue States blocking
Trump and the way this view is viewed by
the public uh is really quite horrific
you know they they view President Biden
on the ropes and the ref just called the
match well this so the just so everyone
understands this tonight essentially the
state supreme Court of
Colorado concluded that the former
president is guilty of a federal crime
that he's never been charged with which
is Insurrection or Rebellion which for
which you know in you he could have been
impeached as president but he has not
been charged with that that's never been
adjudicated so so with that could
Republicans to your point say well by
undermining us sovereignty by Le leaving
the Border open President Biden is
trying to undermine the US Constitution
it's tantamount to an Insurrection it's
a broad view but he's going to have to
be taken off the ballot of you know name
your red
State well this court just handed
partisans on both sides uh the ultimate
tool to try to uh shortcut elections and
it's very very dangerous I mean this
country is a powder cake and this court
is just throwing matches at it and I
think that uh it's a real mistake but I
think that they're wrong on the law you
know January 6 was many things most of
it not good in my view was not
Insurrection it was a riot that doesn't
mean that the people responsible for
that day shouldn't be held accountable
uh but to call this an Insurrection for
the purposes of
disqualification uh would create a
slippery slope for every state in the
Union this is a time when we actually
need democracy we need to allow the the
voters to vote we need to hear their
decision and the court here just said
you're not going to get that uh in
Colorado we're not going to let you vote
for Donald Trump no and you know you
could dislike Trump you could believe
he's responsible for January 6 but this
isn't the way to do it I mean it is you
know for people that say they're trying
to protect democracy this is hands down
the most
anti-democrat opinion I've seen in my
lifetime and it's worth noting that
three of the judges in descent were also
Democrat appointees the whole Court's
appointed by Democrat Governor so it was
right down the middle 4-3 decision again
the country hangs in the balance the
Court's going to have to decide this
Jonathan thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else